claude lévi-strauss ma première question
est somme toute logique
qu'est-ce que l'ethnologie à quoi
servent les ethnologues et au fond que
quoi servi à quoi sert claude lévi
strauss oui la dernière je me chargerai
votre mère l'ethnologie en général vous
savez c'est une des nombreuses manières
d'essayer de comprendre l'homme si on
veut comprendre l'homme ont peu à la
manière du philosophe se replier sur soi
même et essayer d'approfondir et donner
de la conscience on peut essayer de
regarder ce qui dans les manifestations
de la vie humaine est le plus proche de
nous considérer notre histoire depuis
ses origines gréco-romaine jusqu'aux
temps modernes ou bien on peut essayer
d'élargir la connaissance de l'homme
pour y inclure même les sociétés les
plus lointaines et qui nous paraissent
les plus humbles et les plus misérables
de manière à ce que rien d'humain ne
nous reste étranger
si je vous en parle bien l'ethnologie ce
serait une sorte de continuation de la
réflexion humaniste sauf que vous allez
chercher les sujets les thèmes de cette
réflexion dans des peuples à comps
clarifiée il n'y a encore pas si
longtemps au chômage
vous avez tout à fait raison car en fait
ce que les hommes de la renaissance ont
entrepris c'est à dire d'essayer de
mieux se comprendre eux mêmes à travers
le regard sur l'homme de civilisation
qui étaient des civilisations exotiques
je veux dire la grèce et rome
c'était une manière de mettre leur
propre société en perspective de se
mettre eux-mêmes en perspective
et puis après ce premier humanisme
il ya eu un élargissement avec le
développement des moyens de
communication des grands voyages
d'exploration
on a intégré
le monde arabe et de la chine le japon
et l'ethnologie représente la troisième
et la dernière étape de cette entreprise
humaniste qui consiste à essayer de
comprendre l'homme par la totalité de
ses expériences et ses réalisations
mais est ce qu'on peut dire des
ethnologues qu'ils vont chercher des
vérités des sagesses qui ne trouvent pas
dans leur propre société
chez eux écoutez je ne dirais pas ça
parce qu'il y a dans notre propre
société aussi des sagesses c'est pas du
tout en train de le rabaisser mais
simplement nous essayons de comprendre
qu'il y en a d'autres et que notre
sagesse est une sagesse parmi des
centaines ou des milliers car chacune
des quatre ou cinq mille sociétés je ne
dirais pas qu'ils ont existé depuis que
l'homme est apparu sur la terre parce
qu'il y en a eu beaucoup plus
certainement mais sur lesquels nous
possédons quelques informations ou qui y
existe encore bien
chacune représente une sage à sa manière
et le ne pouvons pas essayer de
comprendre la nôtre sans la mettre en
perspective par rapport à tout seul donc
l'ethnologie nous invite à une sorte de
modestie d'humilité
je crois que ça a été en somme sa
fonction d'eux puisqu'elle est apparue
dans notre littérature si vous regardez
ses premières manifestations chez
rabelais ou chez montaigne car ce sont
les premiers qui est une curieuse et
ethnographique
c'est essentiellement dans leurs pensées
pour faire une critique de nos croyances
de nos coutumes nos institutions mais
par critique je ne voudrais pas du tout
employer un terme qui pourrait être
dépréciatif critiquer c'est essayer
d'analyser c'est essayer de comprendre
c'est d'essayer de mettre en rapport
avec d'autres modes de billets d'autres
modes de pensée